on this episode I'm a little under the
weather but it made me thoughtful
[Music]
ask Gary B
[Music]
what's up everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 187 of
the ask gary me show been a little bit
under the weather
Mike Mike the trainer got me sick
said he had a migraine the next day was
like full flew down and it was like what
and then like the thing and the throat
and indeed getting sick
I think it's mental I've told everybody
I refuse to get sick so I've been
fighting it off mentally and so India
let's get into the show so a week from
the book can we get a book we got a book
here or anything there we go that's a
good inside joke a week away from the
book which I'm super excited about and
and thank you all so much for your
support and and so here it is it's very
exciting my dad is super pumped he's in
it but he's like his hair is flopping in
the wind and he's super sad about it so
dad too bad and Oh Alex what he got Alex
what are you doing alright let's do it
right here in the middle of the show I
just do it while I talk about the book I
was talking about books anyway so can I
just yeah you gotta set me up
anyway um this would be a great time to
throw my right hook so many of you have
supported me on super 8 and I thank you
so much but it would mean a lot to me a
big spike the week before on Amazon is
quite important actually for how they
order more and how they promote so if
you were considering to buy the book at
any point in any way or any shape or
form
1 2 3 700 this would be an amazing time
to do so it would mean the world to me
Jesus could look at the difference in
thickness patooties
this is nuts holy crap that's how thin
brush it is
it feels so small I've been asked are
these obese I uh Wow there I'm pumped I
can write the next book in like one day
like you know like no wonder the audio
took one day with crush it and six years
with mascara V so thank you guys so much
I appreciate all the support it's
obviously been a lot of book talk that's
coming to an end sooner than later so
back to our regularly scheduled two
years of jabbing minimum and that's that
notice how there's never thank you
an economy pisses me off so bad it's my
best book it's literally I feel like the
economy is my sister my sister is the
best where we never talk about her she's
in the middle that Liz I think you are
the Thank You economy yes my wife and
sister's name is the same so that's that
daily be is rock and rolling if you
haven't checked it out stephane throat
up right here episode 18 was posted
today it's a good one d-roc is in the
middle of 19 right now who's this go to
sandy sandy like sa ND right okay more
Jo are GE
sorry for the boredom done hey J hey
yeah we're in the middle of the
askgaryvee show oh you're filming right
now right now - oh okay cool thank you
were not going I know I know you got
caught off-guard by the signing yeah we
do
don't worry cool India let's get this
show anyway it would mean the world to
me link up anything you can link up if
so you can link up in YouTube directly
Amazon do it put it in the copy of
Amazon and Facebook right now is the
time to buy the book if you're debating
it at all one two three four five six
copies please it would mean the world to
me
today's a big day and leave a comment
drive back from Connecticut tonight he's
probably having something like thirty
four hours yeah please leave a comment
if you did with the number you just can
leave the number three one seven four I
want to on the way home I'm gonna reply
and thank you one by one that's how
important it is for me tonight India in
YouTube and Facebook then we're getting
to forget it oh my god does look like
Ben Ben Ruby and his name's Ben hey Gary
I just wanted to find out how you Scout
vine Arminius so quickly do you do joint
ventures or partnerships what strategies
allowed you to Skousen
you know I think the number one
overarching thing with me is that I'm
you know in a place where I'm a top-line
revenue driver right because I'm able to
drive sales and was able to get clients
you know a funny thing happens money
solves a lot of business problems by
having money continue to come in I'm
able to over invest and so right now
most of our organization you know is not
actually at capacity you know we talk a
lot about capacity here at vaynermedia
we probably have 20 percent more
capacity meaning people can be on more
accounts and we can be get paid for it
most agencies would drive that down to
even-steven even sometimes under
capacity to drive profit I am near their
hand really because of my ability to
sell that's what it is because of my
ability to sell I'm able to drive growth
at such a rapid pace parallel that with
HR capabilities and actually caring
about people and scaling
charm be an HR driven CEO you have the
two combinations for hyper growth
companies one that cares about its
people and one that's able to make money
it's really not complicated and then a
third variable of one that's not being
built to sell so I'm not worried about
my margin because when you sell your
company you're often not look at that
pond at your revenue you look upon how
much money you're making people paying
you in a multiple on that because I'm
not worried about that I'm four more
dollars into people into culture into
being on the offense into opening up
London if those were things that if I
was trying to sell this company I
wouldn't open up London I wouldn't have
twenty percent extra capacity I'd be
trying to organize it and orchestrate it
orchestrate it to a sale and so I think
it's a mentality and then I think it's
the capabilities of me on a CEO level on
sales and HR Gerardus you mentioned
publicly documenting one's journey but
isn't advertising an experience hurtful
when seeking paying clients confused one
more time I said the other day in Delhi
be that it would have been cool to see
Vera Wang or woulda been cool to see me
starting Wine Library right Jarrod you
should not be paid for faking the funk
you should not be a twenty year old life
coach telling people how to live their
lives because you're just starting yours
you should not be paid as an advertising
expert if you're not an advertising
expert I mean unless I'm wrong here and
I don't think I am it seems like Jarrod
is talking about the classic fake it
till you make it which so many people
get away with and you're more than
welcome Jared if that's what you're
saying and maybe maybe you're not but
I'm gonna use it as an opportunity to
talk to everybody right now yes I think
that telling the truth exposes the
things you want to lie about yes I do
yep Bobby
no he improvised I thought about hi Gary
it's Bobby here if you were selling
custom animated Instagram videos for
companies how specifically would you
find buyers today given that it's not
something that the majority of companies
are jumping on just yet
thank you I would do exactly what you're
doing Bobby you hustled your way into
the askgaryvee show this was just shown
a lot of people are gonna now know about
you let's throw up
Bobby's Instagram handle if we can
figure that out can we right here I just
gave you six or seven leads I would
highly recommend that you do it for a
very low price for the vaynernation
because one of the things that people do
when they're selling something that's
the future is they over price their
service unique case studies you need it
out in the wild and so instead of
whatever you're charging for them if you
cut that by a you know 3/4 and give the
vaynernation a good deal on it they're
gonna post on their Instagram that's
gonna lead to awareness on you and so
couple things one growth hacking
hustling exactly what you did here the
other thing is you I would go to a lot
of the accounts that you're seeing on
Instagram that have a lot of followers I
would search hashtags I would use
Explorer I would go to their account
let's get right into details I don't
know if he may be able to see this but
let's get real practitioner today I
would go in into uh you know Instagram I
would go into Explorer I would refresh
so I'm in my Explorer I would look at
the different accounts there's a golf
picture looks nice Scottish golf podcast
right 5,000 followers it's a Scottish
golf podcast I would say cool I can do
animations around golf and so well I
would look now they put their snapchat
account they don't put their Gmail most
people do put their Gmail and that would
have led me to emailing them and saying
hey I saw your Scottish golf podcast
Instagram account here's my animated
things I'd like to get some exposure I
normally charge 300 bucks for it but not
because you're one of the first people
I'll give it to you for 30 bucks or
maybe free and you can post it on your
account now because there's no email
here the only URL is their podcast so
I'm hitting yes here now I'm going to
they're calm and my hope is here I will
find their email so I can contact them
I'm going all the way to the bottom
because it's where it tends to be and I
do not see it now I see their Twitter so
I'm gonna click the Twitter and now I'm
on here so I'd probably reply to them on
there and say hey
so I'm just doing that cuz it's funny
but that's what I would do I would grind
but people don't remember and what I
don't talk enough about with Wine
Library TV is that nobody watched the
goddamn show and so what I just did on
social media I used to do on the
Internet I used to search the word wine
and go 40 50 60 pages deep and Google
results
you know 400 500 600 results deep click
every link find a blog find their email
and email them and ask them if they
wanted to bizdev if they wanted an
interview if they wanted my content if I
could bring them value to give me
exposure these were sites that nobody
was thirty people 40 people 60 people
and I hustled and I hustled and I
hustled and I hustled and I hustled and
so that's what you can do you can do
what you just did with me you can go
through a rabbit hole on Instagram that
I wish I had when I started Wine Library
TV and you put in the work to bizdev one
by one by one from the Scottish golf
podcast to the India art producing
Instagram to whatever you do and so
that's what I highly recommend it's the
grind on the biz dev hustle that matters
James asked how would you deal with a
co-founder who isn't as ambitious as you
I'd break up with them I think that if
you have a co-founder that's not as
ambitious as you are you're leading to
an inevitable breakup and I would try to
cut it earlier so that feelings aren't
as deep it's easier to break up with
somebody after three weeks than it is
after three months and it is after three
years right and so there's less baggage
now the co-founder may be so talented
and brings you value then maybe you
don't have to judge them on ambition but
I would say that when you and your
co-founder are not aligned you're you're
headed towards a negative and so I would
communicate first I'm giving you the
finish line but what I would start with
is I'd be like hey India can we have a
coffee sure yeah so listen I really
think that I have bigger ambitions for
this business than you do and I'd like
to talk to you about that yeah it's
definitely true and so I think you had
that conversation one of the things that
it's led to and I've given this advice a
lot is that Indy and I who started off
at 50/50 India recognises that
sees that I'm putting in 18 hours a day
and she's putting in seven and she may
say you know what I still want to ride
that train I believe in us I can't do
that
I'm not as ambitious I don't have as
much energy I don't want to I have I
have things at home that I want to do
did into the dirt maybe I should give
you back and now you have 70% and I have
30 and so really there's always a deal
to be had if the deal ends up being 100
zero is I don't value India even at 30
or you gonna 20 or even at 10 or even at
zero well then you have to break up but
everything in life every relationship
you know boss and an employee boyfriend
and girlfriend partners in business
cousins
mom and dad every every relationship on
earth is predicated on communication and
you have to have the you have to have
the backbone to step up and actually
have that conversation and have it in a
truthful man manner and it's super scary
and a lot of people are intimidated by
it and I'm not I took me a long time to
get good at it I still don't always get
great at it but it is the only answer to
this question it's about having the
conversation and seeing where the things
fall because a lot of times the other
person doesn't want you to bring it up
they may you know recognize it sometimes
they don't even recognize it some people
are blind and lack self-awareness so you
need to make sure you're connected and
whatever that arrangement is Sarah
competition because it can drain you and
make you second-guess yourself and
everything like that but I you know
through my business that isn't things
like that I've realized that or I've
been taught that you can't operate in a
silo you know your landscape you have to
keep your eye on the landscape of your
industry so my question is what do you
think about competition and how you
approach it
Thanks name again Robert Arthur Sarah
thank you so much I like the taxi photo
in the background um you know this is a
tricky one I think this comes down to
the individual eye I don't spend a lot
of time in my car
I haven't historically but I keep a you
know a fifth of an eye on it you know
you got you want to know context you
can't be blind to things completely but
I don't dwell or allow my competition to
drive my mentality or where I'm going I
think it's a very fine line I think it's
a very very fine line and I think it's a
very individual thing so I don't know
much about the agency world as a whole I
don't know the names of most of the CEOs
I don't know how much revenue they're
doing I don't know who their clients are
I don't know what the work they're doing
a lot of my contemporaries spend all
their time on at age and and digit day
and other websites to keep up with
what's going on PR week and week in the
trades I think that there's a lot of
entrepreneurs that do extremely well by
knowing what's going on with their
competitors and using that as a proxy as
a guiding light I think a lot of
entrepreneurs are being see
entrepreneurs and they need somebody
else to be the leader and they follow it
and they pick up the crumbs and they get
20 and 30 percent of the action and
that's enough for them and that's where
they deserve to be I think others like
me are super driven by not knowing I
don't even want to give my competition
the satisfaction of knowing I mean I
literally hate my competition so much
that I literally want to be
disrespectful by not even amassing a
minute of my time on what they're doing
because I think that's the ultimate
insult and I like that because I don't
like you competition I don't like you
now I like you as a human being right
like like in when I put my jersey on I
hate you but as like a human there's
plenty of executives from competitive
agencies that I adore and think of
really good people but when I put my
jersey on I hate you and the way that I
can teach you that I hate you is to not
even allocate a minute on you because I
disrespect you that much that's me you
you may be somebody who learns from your
competitors and that's how you navigate
so I do not think that anybody who
taught you one way or the other in
fatica Lee
don't forget askgaryvee show I'm one
dude with one personality trait with you
know one life that is trying to
communicate my points of view but I
never and I've said this on dailyvee
recently I have no interest in you
following you know my footsteps I have
you I have interest in you trying to
figure out yourself the way I figured
out myself
right I know that about me so I don't
force myself to look at the competition
because I know deep down it's not who I
am or what I want to be doing and so I
know that about myself you need to know
yourself and it may be a balance
some people are 50/50 it all works if
you're most self-aware about you pushing
day what's the question they what's the
biggest thing you've learned about
yourself this year and we're only eight
weeks in India what about you what's
that yeah it's a good one caught you
yeah yeah in the last nine weeks or
whatever we're at eight weeks what's the
biggest thing into I know you got
something so give me some depth
no don't notice it no we're gonna cut it
off as a cliffhanger yes say it of
course no no I was joking I desperately
want you to be around people like 24/7
yeah super extroverted right like you
would keep a boyfriend around just
because you thought you needed it what
do you mean making it hard like a
painter this is my favorite meme yeah
you know what's funny I like to be alone
and that freaks people out I like flying
because of that I like taking a poop and
a shower because of that I really don't
mind being alone either I'm like
stunningly chameleons I'm pumped with
80,000 people on stage one person on
stage you know listening to me by myself
I'm I get it I value alone time quite a
bit a lot more than I think I bet you a
ton of people are like whoa just now
that's cool
Stefon anything you learned about
yourself this year
you know I like that one yeah that's
good
you keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
[Music]